[Music]
no one can predict the future but we can
make a pretty good guess about the Madam
web box office from to late sequels to
spin-offs no one asked for these are the
movies we bet you won't see in 2024
Sony's Universe of something about
Spider-Man is the weirdest thing going
in movies right now the Venom movies
have done pretty well for themselves by
embracing stupidity but craving the
hunter looks like a different story why
do you think it will bomb three words
it's morbin time the Spider-Man spin-off
morbius was DOA at the box office
earning a malnourished $162 million
against a $75 million budget the little
Casher did manage to rake him was not
nearly enough to justify Matt Smith's
take on the emo Peter barer dance and
certainly not enough to justify another
Spidey spin-off in Craven the hunter
Craven Stars Aaron Taylor Johnson as
weirdly accent Russian Big Game Hunter
Sergey karavanov who was left for dead
by his father after being mored by a
lion because and this is a quote he's
weak like his mother
boo but it's not just any lion either
it's a magic lion or something with
magic blood that gives him the magic
power to kill people he basically ends
up as a landbased Aquaman a tiger King
if you will I don't think we're done
blowing up today Craven the hunter might
end up being a decent movie but all
signs so far that the audience isn't
there for It characters like Craven and
the Rhino are at their most interesting
and they're fighting Spider-Man without
him these villain movies feel like they
don't really have a
point he was in the Amazon with my mom
when she was researching spiders right
before she died with $ 8.9 billion in
the bank worldwide across 10 films
Spider-Man is about as close to a sure
thing as you're going to get at the box
office but his amazing
friends we already predicted that Craven
the hunter will Flatline at the box
office and Madame Webb will Fair no
better even though it does look a lot
funnier Dakota Johnson stars in the film
as Cassie Webb AKA Madame Webb whose
psychic powers give her the ability to
see within the spider world it's a slam
dunk concept look how excited she is to
be there I have always really loved
Marvel movies hilarious this doesn't
look like a slow motion car crash at all
we're not sure who the audience for this
movie is but are Peter tingle is telling
us to be pretty small it's not working
though I heard it wasn't working right
now is it it is working well I I don't
know if it's working okay so get Peter
tingle as funny as the first trailer is
morbius already proved that memes don't
make the movie but we'll give Sony this
at least it does look like a slightly
better idea than the Aunt May movie they
were rumored to be thinking about 10
years ago you're not Superman you
know some of the greatest comedies ever
paired their lives with a little dollop
of dread think Ghostbusters and Beetle
Juice or even spooky spoofs like Young
Frankenstein and scary movie but the
horror comedy shrunken head juggling Act
is a tough one to master it's a sub
genre that has left a pile of cinematic
corpses in its wake for example see 2022
is
Renfield yeah no not many of you did as
a vampire comedy sucked up an anemic $26
million worldwide on an $86 million
budget turns out Nicholas Cage as Count
Dracula wasn't an exciting enough
premise to get people out of their
coffins in 2024 we'll be getting another
classic horror character but with comedy
in Lisa Frankenstein
bogus bogus described as a coming of
Rage Love Story which fine we sort of
hate how clever that is the genre
bending flick is about a young girl Who
develops a relationship with a
reanimated corpse because you know
puberty isn't gross and gooey enough or
whatever Lisa Frankenstein was written
by Oscar winner deblo Cody who won Gold
for Juno but more importantly she pens
Jennifer's Body while Jennifer's Body is
a cult classic now it's underwhelmed
with $31 million in 2009 without Megan
Fox at the height of her star power and
the lead we predict that Lisa
Frankenstein May raise the dead but it
won't raise a ton of money in other
words it might have been better to keep
this idea
buried move on.org needy it's over
following the Decades of sequels
prequels reboots and remakes were're
always interested in an original premise
but there is one big thing with the
original Prem premises the audience has
to know what the hell is actually going
on at least if you want it to make any
money frankly the upcoming Argy has a
scratching our heads at first glance
it's similar to Romancing the Stone or
the L city with a mousy spy novelist
Ellie Conway played by Bryce Dallas
Howard getting tossed into a real world
tale of Espionage also Katherine O'Hara
is in it this time not dressed as a
mutated cuman hybrid and mermaid Ken and
Barbie obviously but that's not Metro
enough for our postmart modern post
Deadpool sensibilities right that's why
the movie also follows a character
Argyle portrayed by Henry caval with a
Bart Simpson heut turns out Argy is
Conway's Superstar sluth who so far as
we can tell is real in his story but
still a fictional character in Conway
story or maybe not this is the kind of
premise that depends on a starcast to
sell it and admittedly this one is
packed more densely than Jason stam's
leopard print unies that said Cav's last
name above the title spy movie 2014's
The Man from Uncle was so sneaky that it
came and went with only $15 million
worldwide on a $75 million budget jury
still out on whether flying that low
under the radar makes it a good spy
movie or not like red notice or
extraction we think Argyle has a license
to kill on a streamer but is a movie
that people leave home and pay money to
see there's no disguising it Ary is a
turkey and it probably won't be gobbling
up those sweet sweet box office books
thanks to Yellowstone Kevin cner went
from being one of the biggest movie
stars of the 1990s to one of the biggest
TV stars right now so basically the same
big time a-lister except he's traded in
his badass Water World traran for an
AARP membership you think he want to
keep riding that gravy train uh boat but
the lore of the Silver Screen is too
much in 2024 cner will return to the
director's chair for the first time in
21 years and acting in and directing the
two-part epic Horizon and American Saga
so we predict he won't have just one
bomb but
two oh thank God sure the promotion will
highlight the fact that ker directed
1990s Dances with Wolves while
conveniently neglecting to mention that
he didn't exactly push the envelope with
this massive 1997 bomb the postman
couple that with water world struggling
to stay afloat with audiences in
1996 and you can see why Cosner's big
screen career never recovered you bought
Tin Cup that's a terrible movie you mean
classic I like Tin Cup but it's a bad
movie right you ever see it no I didn't
see it well he leverages roll as a
patriarch of TV's Dutton Clan into a
cinematic comeback doubtful while we
don't know the exact budget we do know
kasner ponied up $20 million of his own
money to help fund his dream project
which he's wanted to do so since 1988 so
either Horizon is too expensive or he's
having trouble finding finances probably
both Prime to out snor Fest a beekeeper
when it comes to boring ass titles the
brick layer is scheduled for a day and
date release meaning it will likely be
released in theaters and Via streaming
video on demand at the same time this is
clearly not a movie that's looking to
break records in theaters or even make
backer's budget so at least they're
keeping the expectations in check based
on the novel of the same name by former
FB Pi agent Paul Lindsay writing under
the pen name Noah Boyd the brick layer
start Aaron echart Nas is a sweaty
mortar splattered construction worker
but is a rebellious former FBI operative
who comes out of retirement to stop some
bad guys we dig earts but we might be
the only ones as his box office
footprint is pretty faint when you take
the Dark Knight and the insert thing
that fell here has fallen franchise out
of the equation meanwhile the brick
layer is directed by renie Harin who had
a moment as an aist director in the
early 1990s with hits like Die Hard 2
and Cliffhanger before Cutthroat Island
ultimately sank his reputation like a
stone given its lack of box office
bonafides we expect the brick layer to
lay an egg death taxes and sequels to
old action movies that your dad really
wants you to like are the three things
you can always count on normally would
be okay with the last one but even the
most passionate Prometheus apologists
Among Us are left wondering do we really
need another alien movie at least alien
ramulus isn't original or well as
original as the ninth film in a
franchise can be before things start
getting all failed
Clon said to be a standalone film un
connected to the previous centuries the
potentially extra terrible
extraterrestrial flick is based on an
original pitch by director fiday Alvarez
Alvarez directed 2013's Evil Dead which
admittedly was better than it had any
right to be and shows he has the horror
bonafides to to back up his ideas
creatively the alien franchise has been
hit or miss since the onew punch of
Ridley Scotts alien in 1979 and James
Cameron's aliens in 1986 the concept of
spooky scary spaceship stocked with
spooky scary aliens seems like it would
lend itself to a metric buttload of
Insidious Ingenuity but the series
creative stagnation is hit it right in
the box office case in point alien
Covenant made a whopping 41% less than
Prometheus pulling in $238 million
versus the latter's $42 million so
heartbreaking almost makes your chest
burst oh no not
again while the film was originally
destined for Hulu release like the
Predator prequel prey 20th century
Studios switch gears and decided to drop
it in theaters we're not saying that
releasing alien Romulus in theaters is a
bad idea but based on the series
downward slide we just don't see alien
Romulus getting anywhere near the
franchises 70s and 80s Heyday and in
space no one can hear your Razzy speech
what's scarier than one tornado well we
could be talking about an EF5 shark NATO
on the upper east side of Manhattan 30
years after twister we're seeing double
with Twisters a movie about tornadoes
just like the original hey Hollywood
tell us you're running out of ideas
without saying you're running out of
ideas the third one's just going to be
twister with a three in it yes twister
was an $88 million movie that in 1996
earned an exceptional
$495 million adjusted for inflation that
is literally almost a billion dollar
with that in mind it's kind of
surprising that it took this long for
tornado season to come around again the
studio is going to be hoping for top gun
Maverick numbers but we're thinking this
one will perform closer to speed two
cruise control for starters there are
reports of lead no stars from the
original movie coming back to ground the
movie in Nostalgia there's also zero
reason for Twisters to exist besides
making money which isn't enough to get
audiences to show up people see through
this kind of thing now you got us with
Star Wars but come on twister who wants
to go back to that world if we're going
to go back to Oklahoma I'd rather watch
Leonardo DiCaprio try and kill the
flower moon now that's cinema right mty
I don't mean to be flip about it but it
is you're right what's John Wick without
John Wick or the stunt team from John
Wick and with the director of Underworld
instead of the director of John Wick
well we're all going to find out whether
we like it or
[Music]
not John Wick is a rare series that made
more money with each sequel the $432
million box office the fourth film made
is almost five times the $87 million
that the original made 9 years earlier
that kind of growth is almost unheard of
in modern Hollywood and pretty much
demands the sequel treatment until the
cash stops coming in frankly we have
zero issues of lines gate making John
Wick chapter whatever follow-ups until
keano Reeves registers for Social
Security but that's the thing isn't it
keano Reeves is only one man so
realizing this conundrum Lion's gate is
attempting to create a John Wick
Cinematic Universe but without John Wick
why first there was the three- Parts
limited prequel series the Continental
oh sorry the Continental from the world
of John Wick on peacock I'm a peacock
Captain you got to let me fly on this
one you know what Terry let's just
settle this peacocks don't fly next
there's the spin-off ballerina which
presumably has something to do with that
ballerina scene in John Wick 3 call us
crazy but it's not the John Wick
universe that movie goers love it's
keano Reeves doing a tactical reload
with the confidence of a guy who
actually knows how to do it it's keano
Reeves doing karate versus cars at the
age of 59 when you remove the star from
the franchise you get trip XX states of
the Union the born legacy and 29 Jump
Street we're sure anade aramos will be
on point as a title ballerina we just
don't think the movie will make a lot of
money now johnwick chapter
Breeze